good morning Millennials good morning
Millennials well what a short weekend
feels like if it's just five [ __ ]
minutes ago we were sitting here what a
short weekend where I woke up early on
both days at 11 a.m. what a short
weekend where I worked half the weekend
okay no I worked at three flights this
weekend I worked all day Sunday on cam -
I slept through the whole thing like I I
was so excited I knew you were sleeping
and I was so excited for you to wake up
so I could just hit you with in the good
news but cam shows pre-sell went on sale
yesterday and regular sale starts today
the second this show ends and we're
gonna be posting the tickets live on the
show once we're done cover yeah and
informing you so just stay tuned you
won't miss it you'll know where they'll
be at and just don't wait to see the
hype from everyone like it's so
appreciated and like now I'm getting
hyped I'm getting hyped but it's also so
far out like typically I don't plan my
life this far oh my god I'm freaking I
mean a from just having plans in May
next year like what if something comes
up you know I already know that I'm
missing a wedding and like I'm also
planning tour for 2019 and they're
sending me all these dates I'm like I
don't know where I'll be I know I just
prefer to do things like a month max out
1,000% I wouldn't be planning my
memorial day weekend until May and now I
know what I'm doing in December
Who am I just yes guys wanna touch my
chest oh it's gonna take so long for me
to not talk about the thank you next
video because that is a story of course
when I was put it first okay how was
your weekend my weekend was good I mean
I'm so effing tired and like I just I
haven't been home on a weekend and so
long like I just like wanted to go out
and it totally like [ __ ] me up cuz if
I just stayed in on Saturday like I
would feel so much better right now but
I went out and I had a good time but
like still I'm so tired and just I
didn't go out on Friday so Friday it's
really annoying because like when I do
shows on the weekdays I really try and
make it so that I can take a flight
after the show so I don't have to miss
the show so I can do the morning show
and the night show but sometimes that
just like makes me tired
so on Friday I did the toast ran to
Alabama the flight was just like not a
good flight for my body like it took a
toll and I was just exhausted and I just
I gave the show my everything I really
did I heard such good things did you and
the toasters
I feel like I never really seed that
much of other than people's meet and
greet pictures right but people were
just like talking about the content of
the show well I just love Alabama like I
really do and I'm try and do like a lot
of the show improv based on where I am
so I was making like a bunch of
hillbillies Oaks and oh my god like I
love that nobody corrected me but like I
was making so many jokes there was this
huge game Alabama game
yes UGA and like yeah I thought it was
taking place in Alabama so it was just
like making all these jokes about I was
- no it was in Georgia I'm like
everyone's laughing and like nobody
corrected me and like that's why I love
the toasters because they like pretended
my jokes were funny when like they were
fairy balls that's so it I I thought it
was Alabama the whole time and you were
saying that the whole city sold out cuz
of the game that was my joke you know
the whole city's empty because I'm
thinking right it was actually quite the
contrary and I think I love a lot of
toasters down when I didn't go out but
like first like I need to live like I
would have died and I had a flight at
7:00 a.m. the next day
and for the most part the toasters were
just like let us know if you not gonna
go it was like work grandma's too and
like we want to go home and I'm like for
sure we were all embracing our inner
Jackie's and we were just like proud of
you so I didn't want people to wait
responsible right I don't want people to
wait like thinking that I was coming so
I was like no I'm not coming there were
a couple girls who like [ __ ] yelled
at me I'm one girl literally yeah I mean
she was like I can't believe like you
would disrespect but she was serious
this girl Christie she was like I can't
believe you would disrespect us that
much like we gave me so much respect and
you just like [ __ ] and I was like what
that makes me so mad because first of
all I never really go about after shows
like I used to do it all the time when I
did at one show a month but it's like
homegirls I am working literally three
times a week now on these shows like I
would die if I went out and drink so
like every now and then I'll do it but
for the most part I don't want to set
the precedent that everyone expects them
great and I don't come and that's the
worst I go home look I know they want to
go home so I totally and for the most
part everyone is like understanding like
okay good we're tired too and like but
some people take it really personally
like this girl [ __ ] Christie with a K
and I was just like I was hurt but like
I really hope I didn't hurt anyone else
like she was legitimately like sad about
it and I was like well first of all
you're unreasonable but second of all
like I'm sorry that's so unreasonable
like you worked so hard on those shows
and by the way like your ticket buys you
a seat at the show like not necessarily
like going out with her after it's a
privilege not a right no and it's like I
that's why every I want to go but then
when I do go I feel like I'm setting the
precedent right oh that's true yeah so
it's like even like when I was in
Alabama last time it was the end of like
the most treacherous week for me Myanmar
going to Buffalo Albany and like I just
wanted to arrange and I went to the
Lauren Alaina concert afterwards and it
was like you know the night demanded out
of me and Alabama demanded that of me
but this was just on the heels of an
exhausting week I had an early flight I
hadn't even been to the hotel yet I went
straight from the airport to the venue
so I still have my [ __ ] suitcase on
do you have your new suitcase no it
hasn't come yet very upset very unfair
when you have your new suitcase oh and
you're gonna experience this like I have
it's really like do you feel pressure to
like look nice at the airport all the
time yeah it's easy for you because you
usually go from the toast so you
actually do look nice but once your
suitcase is queued then like you want to
take a picture with it so you're like oh
my so you have to be cute and now I
travel a little bit cuter than I did
before these shoes have helped well when
I travel directly after the toast I
automatically look a little bit more
elevated yes but I changed into leggings
and I take my makeup off anyway beard
you're gonna feel a little pressure
about the suitcase I started latias and
I [ __ ] lost it it's this tiny little
thing isn't it expensive it was $150 I
don't have insurance
so now I gotta wait hold on I needed to
text the nurse I need another [ __ ]
prescription I'm at x-ray yesterday I'm
wasting two days now like I need also
about Granton dilash you should also
take some hair gummies oh yeah they're
everywhere I lost my keys I couldn't
believe I lost it check my legs oh
really
very hairy my outsides just haven't been
shaving but um yeah it goes your hair
every it's just you're all your hair
grows quickly but I mean Jackie were
joking because cam toast is gonna be
Linton it's like only it's been
literally the only thing I think about
and we thought it would be so funny cuz
one of the partners for the sponsors of
the show is you Cora which we love and
we were like we need to have them as a
partner I can't oh so they could just
like sponsor a pool party on something
like literally and for those who don't
know what you Cora is it's powder it's
pink lemonade flavored right it's pink
powder
tasty you put it in your water it
dissolves and it's preventative for UTI
so it's like if you ever feel like
you're traveling a lot or I don't know
have been in a bathing suit a lot or
just have had general poor hygiene a lot
which it definitely happened to me or
you want to provide their way yeah and
you like you don't pee after sex if you
want to prevent UTIs as opposed to just
waiting for one to show up and then
knocking it out you Quora does that and
it tastes really good and I've been on
it now for probably a month and known
UTIs insight and then you also not only
do that to prevent UTIs but like your
mind it's because I mind and you know
what you can't put a price on peace of
mind but if you could but if you could
you could get you Quora and say goodbye
to UTIs right now you Korra's offering
30 percent off when you text toast to
four eight four eight four eight but
hurry this is a limited time offer text
toast two four eight four eight four
eight to get thirty percent off your
order of you kora that's tio ast two
four eight four eight four eight I just
did gonna be a great brand alignment for
us and I'm gonna talk to them especially
among the pool party right and by the
way I just want to say that there is
turning out to be a large male
population I can't toast like they might
even get to bug this year yeah or I'd
like all their own bunk right if they
want it's all if you have such like neat
accommodations at camp toast it can
happen we are very a constant feels like
I want to come with my mom and I'm like
damn we should have a moms bunk totally
done during odd bunk
there was a mom at my Chanel Jackie she
was so glamorous like Idol was obsessed
she the see Louie Vuitton bag her
daughter was stunning and her she was
stunning and they were just like
southern charm Elliott's nice and but I
have a message for you because there was
a man at the show this girl's husband he
was so cute and so Alabama man had like
the biggest beard ever he looked like he
was in Zac Brown Band and he is in love
with you and his wife knows he was like
yeah we love her like they love you
together thank you he was really like
you actually thought he loves you a lot
for how much she was saying in front of
his wife okay
and he just wanted to send his regards
oh thank you I'm so glad I'm so glad
it's like a a mutual above water thing
in your relationship but the exact and I
have people like that that ladies love
on TV Kate Upton I think that's me and
Ben's um Liz Gillies yeah I'm loveless
oh and Madeleine he loves her well
that's nice
that would make sense yeah yeah that
would be like Ben loving like you know
Adriana Lima's cuz you look so similar
don't worry we'll get to all the
Victoria's Secret stuff oh so I'm we
each have a dogs bucket cam toast
because by then I might have a son fetus
so I reached out to the breeder fur CEO
and I said do you have a cousin I wanted
to retro relative of Theo for my sister
and he was thought he just immediately
sent me a picture of this dog who looked
a lot like Theo and he was 12 weeks old
he was his puppy he's Theo's cousin he
see his cousin and he might be Jackie so
we would really need deals cuz i'm work
on getting a dog zach has accepted his
fate and I'm so excited
it sounds so soon I'm not in a position
right now just like too many things to
juggle to train a new dog but by May um
I think it might happen well I mean I'm
just so excited for so many reasons like
one it's like you where I I they're like
go on vacation or something like I can't
think of a better place to leave Theo
than like in your care with your son
right now it's his cousin with his
cousin and Theo really craves like
socialization with other dogs and he
doesn't really get it a lot because
there's no dogs in my building he's not
a part of like any community so like
when he sees dogs on the street he but
sniffs like crazy and I just think you
bringing on Leo will really enhance his
life saxophones sold on the name is the
only thing but I'm flexible with that
please I'm gonna dog of my tricky advice
it's either Leo Clio sore Gio or Rio or
Thor or four but Thoris like a little
too similar to Theo it's okay I would
literally anything Zach wants I yeah
what if zach wanted like beatrice done
it's like shake you see I can make
anything cute and by the way sounds
Neches yeah son smooches is his name ss
not s no no definitely not when I said
it ya know I mean it's like so annoying
I would never give him your dog Stalin
they have sent me probably ruin initials
you know like stop anyways I'm really
excited about that um I just wanted to
share that promising update with you
guys because I know we've all been in
this journey together we truly have
without further ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast because so many of
our usual suspects that we try to avoid
talking about really came to a head this
weekend and there was a lot of news and
if you follow a news it was unbearable
and I'm really I'm almost out on them I
can't think of did you see their royal
[ __ ] last night yes they did and I'm
so glad you caught it I'm so well
actually I didn't I stole a screenshot
from the toasters and posted it but it
said you just know whoever did that got
fired I don't think they got fired
because
it could have been so much worse no and
also it's like it's an honest mistake
it's an honest mistake it doesn't reveal
and Washington Post when they did the
obituary for George HW Bush I guess a
lot of news organization organizations
have pre-written yeah they pitch ooh air
ease that like are like he died of blank
and they fill in the blank when it
happened and they left the Blake's he
was like he died of fill in reason for
death oh my god it's like mad libs yeah
it was really bad
look that's worse that's generate just
respectful that's terrible and it like
really pulls back the curtain on like
how the media is just waiting for people
to die so they can get some clicks and
like [ __ ] foul did you see George HW
Bush's dog I did Sully it was the first
thing I saw this morning I mean I saw
that and I got a text message from this
crazy person and like between those two
things like my morning was ruined but
especially the slowly thing and the fact
that the dog was named Sully like full
circle full circle of course of course
somebody has an Instagram and he posted
a picture of him in front of the casket
oh I thought you meant soley soley soley
no Ramona you know we're meeting slowly
tomorrow I know I know
I'm ready thinking of what I'm gonna say
not sound nuts what do you say to your
favorite pilot nobody you say to your
hero but like who's a pilot right you
say good wave travels the way you flew
that plane or you say my III captain
yeah or then you go like this and he
goes as you I'm gonna say [ __ ] those
birds you showed them you showed those
birds yeah ain't no we're gonna stop you
Sully but Sully the dog posted to his
Instagram I picture him in front of the
casket caption mission complete because
he was a service dog right no like I
have been not like Theo morbid but like
could you imagine Theo posting that's a
pup with no job I think the saddest
thing like on this planet is dogs who
outlive their owners cuz you're really
not supposed to like the way that like
the life cycle works and I've been
mentally preparing myself to watch dogs
on Netflix I just don't think I can do
it like you know they have that new
series and it's all about dogs and
there's a whole episode on service
animals and it's like apparently this
Sat like not even sad it's just like
meaningful and this like ignited that
same feeling I mean like I went up Mac
Miller passed away and Arianna took his
dog I saw meme and it was like the dog
doesn't know like he just like his owner
left forever and it's like
oh my god kill me no I was thinking but
don't kill me because I'm deal wonder
where I went I was thinking about my new
son last night and I was thinking
already how much like I love him and my
heart is just bursting like with
happiness and it's like so crazy I'm
gonna feel so like the way that I feel
aren't the oh I'm gonna feel all the
time I know it's just like they say you
can't buy happiness but you can't get a
dog it's so crazy but and then I was
thinking like oh my god I love him so
much already like I'm gonna be so upset
when he inevitably dies and then I was
thinking maybe I just shouldn't get the
dog so that I don't have that weed so I
don't I can avoid that pain but it's
like I'd rather have that pain just like
for an instance and also have a lifetime
joy than neither like you're supposed to
experience pain highs and lows what's
the point of I judge not and I tell you
something experience things last night
mean ben-amun we're gonna sleep okay and
Theo has been sleeping at the bottom of
the bed and when he gets really tired
he's the best cuz like you could lay
with him however whatever position he
won't move so we picked him up on his
back and me and Ben likes were like
hugging sleeping and sandwiched Theo in
the middle like and my head was laying
on Theo's chin and I don't think I've
ever experienced such happiness and joy
in my life and I thought I'm like this
is what Jackie's gonna get like that
like literally I turned and I was like
this life and I was like I feel like the
years between getting married and before
you have kids are like suppose to be
like the best like you were like having
no responsibilities and I'm like been
like those years like we're living in
them right now and they're so great he
was like they're literally so great
because of the like he has brought so
much love light and happiness into my
life like I can't and I just want that
for you thank you and I'm so excited I
will come would be getting it soon and
it's I feel like it's important to have
a dog before you have kids because once
you have kids you have your hands full
and it's like impossible trailer dog I
don't want my dog biting off the cheek
of a child that's why we're sad my job
is to fight my kids cheek off and also
once my dog is trained and then I have
kids it's like there's two species that
are the same size at the same time and
they'll I feel like they'll just have a
connection for life and we've never had
that as kids we never had a dog that we
were like you saw eye to eye with right
and a kid like a kids who grow up with
dogs you like you learn a lot of good
responsibilities hopefully when you grow
up with the dog it just teaches you a
lot about like maternal instinct and
things like that the only thing is I'm
not gonna be able to sleep as late as I
used as I normally do but
that is a price I'm willing to pay well
in the first couple months you're gonna
like wanna die and be like why did I do
this and then a day happens and it just
turns and it's like you can't imagine
life without and do and I have slept
till noon maybe later okay noon is
little early for me but we'll see
anyways now without further ado here are
the Fast Five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast we did that
already I know I just wanted to do it
again because we didn't do the story
yeah no we did
Priyanka Chopra marries Nick Jonas in a
Hindu wedding ceremony saying I do is
twice as nice for Priyanka and Nick
on Sunday the pair Wed in a Hindu
ceremony at the umaid bhawan palace in
Jodhpur Rajasthan Rajasthan people
confirmed Chopra 36 and Jonas 26 first
tied the knot in a Western ceremony
which took place on Sunday for the event
the Quantico actress is said to have
worn a red sari whereas the pups are
donned a turban and traditional attire
it is super important to Priyanka to
have an Indian ceremony that honors her
heritage and culture just as important
just as it's important to also have a
Western ceremony that honored Nick's
Christian upbringing and insider shared
with people for Saturday ceremony Chopra
and Jonas as well as their star studded
bridal party wore designs from Ralph
Lauren though the newlyweds have been
busy this weekend they've also taken
time to share bits of the festivities
online here we saw including the
pre-wedding Sangeet and party and the
mehendi ceremony okay so they had them
like America's Got Talent
ceremony for their wedding like where
all of their bridal parties and friends
and family like put on a talent show for
them like similar to like American Idol
like it what it was like big and
spectacular really yeah I guess that's
like a cool there's which is cool but
it's my god I wish I did that so here's
what time's the tow I'm so confused
well because I stick to my guns that
like actually I don't know because you
know what I was also thinking about
something like I'm so confused okay and
I know so many people feel this way
because on the one hand like according
to the blinds like this is a sham
this is PR stunts that is just going so
well for all of them but I mean at all
they think it's really making them love
each other as like and building a bond
of friendship businees bond like
everything but then on the other hand
I'm like now that Shawn Mendes has
really turned on his bike on its head
things
people just put out about people that
you don't know whether or not they're
true now I'm like okay let me look at
this a little more with a little bit
less of a skeptical I like Nick Jonas
has always had a thing for older women
yes yes he did don't a good rim and Kate
Hudson and Kate Hudson exactly so that
makes sense
Priyanka I guess Nick Jonas is a stud
yes but like I feel like trying to
understand my Prien cos with Nick is
harder to understand that they might
Nick is good I mean of course and that's
like okay so there was a big argument in
the toasters that I wanted to bring up
and I wanted to I saw that pose too so
someone said that a lot of people who
doubt Nick and just have like that
they're like haters a lot of those like
opinions are rooted in like ageism
racism sexism like she's an older woman
she's Indian and he's like a young
Christian white and I didn't agree with
it only because I think my argument and
I think the argument of everyone is like
I put Priyanka on the same level star
wise as I can Amal Clooney she was at
the Royal Wedding
she's very cosmopolitan she's best
friends with Nick and Marcos she's in it
unaccomplished Bollywood and Hollywood
actress like her roster her resume is
full and I just don't really see or like
understand what she sees in like this
boy bander this glorified like pop star
and I just think she's too sophisticated
too elegant to be engaging in this kind
of Sharad so I don't necessarily agree
with with what a lot of people are
saying like you couldn't dislike someone
for reasons of having to do with
anything other than gender sex race
whatever like I just my argument is that
I don't know what Priyanka sees in Nick
okay now I understand what she's getting
out of this I cover a book I told me but
I feel like she could have married
anyone remotely famous and been on the
cover but like that's her star power
right like if he went with you know some
whatever and I just feel like the
wedding was so beautiful and I don't I
don't know I'm not familiar or I don't
really understand these Indian
traditions but they seem really
beautiful and it's like sad that they
might all just be in jest that's why I
was thinking it but then I saw this
talent show thing where all of their
friends and family put on these
outrageous acts for them like dances
craziness and it's like if this is all
fake imagine being like Priyanka is
distant cousin they're like hey we need
you to come up with a dance ID for the
skit or the fake wedding like
would be like [ __ ] no but if they were
if I'm crackin station cousin they're
like come up with a dance for the
through a real wedding for the mehendi
ceremony I would be like let I love my
cousin of course I'm is this gonna be on
vogue that's what I would say I just I
really am I'm having a hard time here
because I see the pictures and I'm like
damn this is cute actually then they
like both released the same exact
pictures with the same exact caption
using the word amalgamation and it's
like I don't understand I don't
understand it and as we've said before
like she went to the Royal Wedding and
he goes to the Radio Disney Music Awards
and I mean he has a Radio Disney Music
word probably a lot probably a lot and
so I'm just I'm confused I'm being a
little less skeptical but I mean I can't
believe they did it like seriously but I
can't because it almost makes more sense
if they're not like you know like a
romantic relationship but it's more
business because then it's like no hard
feelings right with Nichkhun with I'm
sorry with Ariana and Pete it's like
when it's so when they love each other
there's so much it's like so but it's
like so but that also is starting to
show signs of maybe it was some sort of
business arrangement because I'm
starting to get a little skeptical of
just the whole thing okay well that's a
great segue into our next story because
ariana grande's thank you next video
came out on Friday and it broke
youtube's record for the most views in
24 hours which is shocking ariana
grande's thank you next video is a
bonafide
overnight sensation it has smashed
YouTube's all-time record for most used
in the first 24 hours of release the
video and homage to female driven movies
from the early 2000s dropped at 12 p.m.
Pacific time on Friday after weeks of
build-up and set the record in just
under 22 hours as of Saturday at 9:30
a.m. Pacific Time Thank You next had 46
million views pushing it past the
previous record-holder kpop supergroup
BTS which not just forty five point nine
million views for their idol music video
in the first 24 hours in August in
addition according to YouTube Thank You
next set the record for most feed video
that used YouTube's premiere scheduling
feature with eight hundred twenty nine
thousand users watching simultaneously
at its peak Grande fans sent over five
hundred and sixteen thousand it's chat
messages during the video debut also a
record for you to premieres the initial
traffic spiked cause delay in comments
posting to the video according to
YouTube
so yeah she broke a lot of Records I
guess BTS held the record but she people
were comparing her to Taylor Swift look
what you made me do which garnered 40
3.2 million views in the first 24 hours
so I mean I've never watched a music
video live and I thought that was cool I
was on the [ __ ] airplane and I
couldn't get on YouTube it was killing
me
and then I eventually like I was in a
bad mood after my flight because like I
said the flight was difficult I mean so
I didn't watch it for like a couple
hours because I didn't want to watch it
in a bad mood
I mean it was really everything that I
had hoped for like all this it was
really done so well in the sense that
like each scene looked exactly like the
movie like that how did they find the
same football field
that bring it on even think about the
eye but like Torrance's bedroom yeah
like to a tee the teeth-brushing scene
was probably my favorite the bend and
snap salon looked exactly like this all
the her outfits were so cute but she's
sitting on that field like reading books
I just love her I love her I loved this
music video and I really was starting to
worry with all the hype around it that I
hate things like that that then it
becomes like bigger than itself but and
I thought this video was gonna be like
10 minutes of just like dumb cameos but
it was so well done so sharp and not too
extra at all the cameos were perfect
Kris Jenner made the video which by the
way if you're in the toasters group you
knew that that cameo was happening yep
someone spoiled inside she was the mom
for Mean Girls so like I was already so
excited it's just further proof again of
what we've been saying is that ariana is
a true millennial like she is our
fearless millennial leader because if I
needed to cast a thirst monster stage
mom of course it would be none other
than the og Kris Jenner none other than
another I mean now I have a lot of
thoughts on it I've been having like a
roller coaster it was really well done
and you know I just I always have to say
something that good and I watch it I
couldn't have had more prime conditions
I was babysitting nephew sneetches I was
on your TV on Roku and I was like it
would promote a three o'clock that was
on fire sir Amazon fire Seca premieres
at 3 o'clock let me get to YouTube so
I'll search it when it goes live I'm
sitting now if you see just is taking a
nap on my lap like just perfect angel
and then I realize it's like a live
premiere so I'm counting
I'm watching the countdown with the
other Orion aiders and then it went live
and Theo and I were just like thank you
next I'm really I find it interesting
the Kris Jenner of it all because you
know you never know like what
celebrities get along and the only real
connection I see between the Kardashians
and ariana grande is Nicki Minaj Ariana
Grande's like besties with Nicki Minaj
but Nicki Minaj went on her
and like [ __ ] blasted Travis Scott
recently and they got this whole
argument I don't really know what it was
about but Arianna is quote with the
Kardashians me remember when Kanye's
concert when it was like the mosh pit
and Kim and Kylie the Kardashians went
down Ariana was with them yeah I think
that North is a fan of Ariana yeah thank
you time Kim went to an ariana grande
concert she went to a Katy Perry concert
I know yeah that too um but I do think
there's like not a divided cuz I think
that divide is over but there was a time
where I was like the Taylor Swift Selena
Gomez crew and then there's like ariana
Miley yeah who at me in the middle who
are just like they're not in the crew
but they are they all cool with each
other
yeah I'm Katie and Ariana are cool too
because Katie performed at one love
Manchester yes
I'm Nicki Minaj's over there and then
yeah so what so Nicki Minaj is like I
should start in the Kardashian is on
this are on this side because Taylor
septa on this side Nicki Minaj is like
making waves though in those kind of
circles because she can't stop like
yelling at everyone on her radio show to
shimmer radio show now Queen radio it's
on beads and that's like her platform
where she just like I mean it's hard for
not getting trouble when you're just
asked to talk for so long like like that
I I so relate to her what is she gonna
say for an hour I don't religion no I
think about everyone I really and I
don't like Nicki Minaj like at all I
think she's a [ __ ] starter like and she
loves it and I think she's a bully and I
think she pits women against two other
women and for someone who's made waves
as a female in history she makes it
impossible for any other females to
become popular robbers or successful
robbers I still like her and then I get
to ride and show on team cardi here I
think she definitely like lowers herself
by getting into like the trenches with
cardi be like she doesn't need to be
doing that but I kind of like how she's
like so shady and just gives us all
these moments of drama no I really don't
like her like I'm so not here for her at
all and I like her friendship with
ariana grande like that I do it's really
cute and they really lift each other up
yes I'm the queen of yep rap young
ariana run pop and honestly that was a
self-fulfilling prophecy because when
she sang that line it wasn't true say
should give you up by the way did you
see the video of me hitting that out yes
but I didn't see how you could have hurt
your back but it was just more of like
an emotional back pain you know I
understand anyway so itself
prophecy because Linda Nikki wrote that
line it wasn't true and now she does run
pop but what's the street thank you next
references let's go first no no but then
I had to talk yesterday that I called
you about yes and you didn't really seem
excited about I thought I thought it was
at more of them I thought it was gonna
be a more layered laugh about it okay
because and actually I saw something in
it and the CDs 50s group about it
because basically what Arianna is doing
now is really very similar to what
Taylor does and what Taylor gets [ __ ] on
for like writing songs about like public
affairs thinking things like that and
then having like sleuthy music videos
but very very subtle like signage with
like oh it's like well she wore this
dress at the time which means it must be
a reference to Kim or whatever so Ariana
her video and her song like I like I
love her and I'm a Stan but Taylor's my
queen and so I really feel like this
whole thank you next is like really like
a brokedown she's best version of
something Taylor's rope with you with
all of her not subtle references it's
like I read a BuzzFeed what prompted
this thought was best me but like 13
things you might have missed and ariana
grande's thank you next video and first
of all they were so not subtle like one
of the things they missed is like did
you realize that the guy who was playing
Aaron Samuels was actually answer I
wasn't like please yes I wasn't born
yesterday thank you but it was like the
things that they were trying to be like
she's so sleepy with her subtle hints it
was a kurta license plate said seven
rings which might be the another song on
her next album like that's not sleuthy
and that's not really subtle and that's
not like Taylor Swift era okay
I hear you and I want to say like I
understand what you're saying I see how
you could see it that way but I actually
think it's not because they're really in
two separate leagues like what Taylor
Swift does is she uses her own life and
her own art as inspiration for further
art ariana grande was just doing a cute
music video based on movies that we love
she wasn't trying to like it was less
art and more just like pop fun yes and
Taylor Swift does these things that have
meaning and we never know what the
meaning is she never comes to firms or
denies it and it's only something in her
well that you know Arianna was more just
like giving people like teasers and
excitements and it's like if you're
gonna have a sign that says Harvard
might not say thank you next or seven
rings which is a song on her new album
so I don't think there's it wasn't
hidden that's definitely one way it was
another way to see it is also just
cheapen to Taylor it wasn't hidden
messages like it was just like symbols
of
album it was a similar thing to what
Taylor does basing Taylor's on a whole
nother level it's not even worth
comparing no but Taylor look I'm just
defensive of Taylor because she gets
[ __ ] on for doing like 90 but some of
the things that literally everyone else
does and they copy her to bone thing
okay I don't worry it all comes back to
Taylor's basically what I'm trying okay
so some of the biggest like messages in
the video first of all the burden book
which just gave us content for days Big
Sean could still get still got it thank
you because because I feel like they
were too soon it's just still with
Jeanne Jeanne Aiko oh I don't know
cuz like I wouldn't be happy if I was he
could still get it exactly Ricky good
times man friends forever friends
forever very cute even though like he
was definitely the like guy but behind
donut gate and that was just like a bad
time that wasn't a good year for Ariana
no and then Matt I'm sorry Pete huge
sorry I dipped sorry I'm just the
funniest thing ever
the funny thing I've also just confirms
that she was going to broke it off
yes for sure and then the fact that Mack
wasn't in the burn book it's like she
doesn't want to burn him no of course he
was an angel because he was an angel i
jus wish it was like a one more thing
like maybe just like a photo of him like
I just I want to respect Mac Miller's
honor I mean honor Mac Miller's memory
in any way that I can and I think she
really did that by not dragging him or
anything anything um what else were
hidden moment 7 rings is I guess a song
on her new album same a needy she
tweeted that she went to twist knees
with her seven friends and they all
bought like diamonds for each other but
don't you think is weird but she
literally just came out with an album
she ended her own era so quickly I
completely agree but I'm also really
glad because sweetener did not do it for
me Sam yeah but it is weird and then
she's also tweeting that she needs a
break but like she's giving herself so
much more gonna have like seriously I
know she so she looked so cute as Elle
Woods and and as Jennifer Garner she
said her hair like that Jennifer
Coolidge crushed it when they stopped to
talk about have you ever dated the guy
with no teeth I was literally laughing
have you ever I mean did you see both
bruce Witherspoon and Jennifer Garner
instagrammed yeah yes but not Kirsten
Dunst ooh
did she even have Instagram Lizzie low
handed to of course oh my god I have to
tell you the money is
Lindsay Lohan tweeted out a link and it
said for those who doubt me watch this
and I watched it and it was unbelievable
it was she narrated this eight-minute
documentary on BBC about child labour in
India and I learned so much they rescued
fifty kids it was like this whole
mission and I was like oh my god like
this is amazing it was from 2010 and I
was like I don't know how I missed that
I wasn't gonna hurt she's making and
come back and then I was reading the
replies and everyone's like why she
posting video from 2010 she's so change
she's proving she hasn't done something
good since in eight years
also life-sized 2 premiered last night
ok I haven't seen it yet so I will not
judge but what I'm hearing is that
everyone besides the gays hated it ok
but if the gays loved it I feel like
then I would like it too I agree I'm
gonna watch it but it's crazy anyone who
doesn't like it it's gonna date didn't
watch it like I'm gonna told me like
when we were I remember when they
announced that there was gonna be a life
says to remake and it was at our old set
like literally the chengqi deaths then
we did the whole song and if someone
came up to me and said that movie's
gonna premiere and you're not gonna
watch it well I was planning on seeing
it when I thought it was in theaters but
it was like a made-for-tv movie and like
I've been in theaters I wanted to go to
the movies so bad this weekend there's
nothing for me to see Sam I would have
had to see life-size channel like I
would have had to see fantastic beasts
it's great no matter where she goes she
dress her up from her head to her toes
at the town at the mall he loves high
fashion after a dark after dawn she'll
spend the whole night dancing
shining bright shining photo and be shot
being a stuff where you live where you
appear such a song such a song oh so I
like I saw that that teaser that we
posted to the toast where they made it
like um EDB yeah rough and I thought
that was very into me too so cool
enemies do you see Tyra Banks on ma
choppin slide yes I just caught up like
I watched like a bunch of clips that
added up to like 15 minutes she is
really like I love her and I think she's
like the it's so funny how she really
has a hand underrated Lee in so many
movies like movies that we love I mean
the click obviously we had her greatest
work I can't believe she was snubbed on
the Oscar for that I know we had Claire
here and she confirmed but she thought
she was never on set but what a lot of
people don't realize it's like she's
like a full time movie producer and she
produces so many movies but obviously I
can't remember any of em but let me just
do a quick google also when they were
talking about her show the Tyra show yep
and they were like is there anything you
regret and you would think she'd be like
oh maybe the time like I wear that fat
suit or something
she was like nothing it was a great time
of my life okay and wait coyote ugly Wow
[Music]
take your time what's crazy is that
she's America's Next Top Model and now
Eve on Atlanta it is what's from n by
the way I was and I didn't realize that
eat Tyra Banks had discovered winning
Harlow and I will do that yeah and
winning Harlow like had some some words
some unkind words for Tyra and Tyra
obviously handled it with you know such
grace elegance in class she really did I
was so impressed The Price is Right
oh no I'm sorry no there's nobody on the
price is right
okay maybe she's not there nobody was a
director just like the click okay I
can't find it but she was she is an
important role okay I'll take your word
for it
whatever I'm sorry anyways I wanted to
talk about that episode because she's so
great and like she needs I need more of
her and I understand why she gotta talk
show now and I just mean I wish it
worked out better cuz I wish she was
still on now Megan Fox was weird was
weird but I really liked her I mean you
could literally see the bones from her
boobs it was the craziest thing ever
she's no she's so skinny she wouldn't
lean back she was like sitting like so
high alert like who could sit on a chair
like this for me because of her jacket
like that like she couldn't slouch
because then nobody would fall out it
was just me she's looked like she was
about to get up like the entire time no
but I liked her because it was I was so
nervous of what she was gonna say adults
I'm so nervous
but she didn't hold back anything she
answered every question yes she did
include says she didn't leave she said
she liked mary-kate better and she said
that she did have a romance of Shia
LaBeouf yeah but she's denies for seven
years and she could have pled the fifth
yeah and like her and her husband
definitely like beat each other up like
she probably beats him up oh my god that
was funny too but she didn't hold back
she liked scares me I really liked her
and she's so gorgeous and I really liked
her and when she was honest I would
happen with Michael Bay she was like I
was like felt really entitled and I
thought that my anger was justified
right I'm just I'd like to be self-aware
for someone who doesn't have to be ya
know Andy always knows what to ask
that's the thing I think he was scared
of her to know she's scary
I just heard in the way that she looks
like she's very intense looking with her
dark hair and her dark eyebrows and
you're like that [ __ ] will kill you
with her eyes yeah when they played that
game about like you're so hot like how
these things happen to you and
everybody's like it yes that's I mean if
it hasn't happened to Megan
and it just doesn't happen period I mean
they were like I think when they asked
have you ever been rejected and Tyra
said yeah of course I think Megan Fox
has never been rejected because she just
said yeah because Tyra said yeah that
was the vibe that I got that's
customarily so real I love Tyra the
entire follow each other and Instagram
that's like one of my favorite things
she might have unfollowed me but I don't
think she didn't I don't think she's
totally taken no matter where she goes
dress her the [ __ ] up that joke I her
head to her toes whether she's at the
town or the mall she loves loves high
fashion after dark after dawn she'll
spend the whole night dancing so
relatable you know what she does she
shines bright she shines far she's not
shy she's a star okay we have to move on
next story
speaking of Tyra Whitney Harlow Halsey
calls out Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
for quote lack of inclusivity Halsey
shared some choice words about the 2018
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show which
aired on Sunday night the show was
filmed on November 8th and included
performers such as herself Shawn Mendes
bebe Rexha chainsmokers and a strong
class of models this year including
Kendall Bella Gigi Behati Winnie Adriana
Lima and others the singer posted her
note in Victoria's Secret colors pink
and white and called out the company's
lack of diversity quote I have adore the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show since I
was young performing this year alongside
other amazing artists and hard-working
models and Friends was supposed to be
the best night of my year however after
I filled the performance some comments
were made regarding the show that I
simply could not ignore as a member of
the lgbtq+ community I have no tolerance
for a lack of inclusivity especially not
one motivated by stereotypes if you're
on my page because you watch my
performance tonight please allow me to
instead direct your attention to GL Sen
an organization that offers services
aimed at protecting LGBTQ plus youth and
with respect to those youth targeted by
these comments in a world where they
have been made to feel quote other I
have made a sizable donation in their
honor
so she's referring to Ed's comments so I
mean I would have been so pissed like if
I had filmed a show and then like
afterwards like these comments were made
and it looks like you've aligned with it
because it's premiered after but nobody
realizes it was filmed before so like I
think this is a very elegant and
graceful way to handle it and I expected
a lot from Halsey and she delivered I
thought it was the perfect way to handle
it meet you I mean I'd hang respectful
like to the the job that she did right
the money
she made and then also honoring people
that like were felt wronged maligned by
these women I mean I didn't watch and I
felt so just like I it was ten o'clock
Margo groped like who's watching and it
could have turned on the channel and I
just did not and I felt really good
about it and also I didn't even see that
much about it because I think I saw the
whole thing already on Instagram
I watched and I'm upset that I watched
and I blamed Shark Tank because I'm so
in love with Shark Tank that I actually
watched it live on ABC last night
because I couldn't miss a moment and it
it led into the Kray Secret Fashion Show
which I wasn't going to watch but then
they started but this is me that's how
they opened the show and I was so upset
like first of all you're gonna ruin my
favorite movie by using the song and why
did they have Kayla settle Sonya bad I
don't know this person who's saying is
saying and finding people that like
didn't like her and ition but I liked it
I thought she had a great voice and I
have no issue with her that is not a
message for you to use no one will love
you as you are has anyone ever said that
to a Victoria Secret change how you look
no one will love you as you are yeah I
don't think that's know that probably
said that lose four more pounds like
that song does not apply to Victoria's
Secret models and if they wanted and I
saw a lot of their marketing is this is
the greatest show on earth so it makes
sense that they would use Grady showman
and as I said here before they should
have had panic at the disco performed
the greatest show and that would have
been in tune using this as me is so out
of touch like I'm sorry but that song
doesn't apply to Victoria Secret models
we listen to this as me because we don't
look like Victoria smart models and we
are another round of bullets has hit my
skin like oh my god it was so that was
the first time I've seen a performance
of that song where I didn't get chills
like what like feel empowered by it
I felt the opposite of empowered I felt
like it was exploitation of the song I
mean between the commercials the three
times the normal performances the
snapchat videos that they apparently
kept using from everyone's snapchat like
where was the show is only an hour right
yeah yeah might have been two hours
oh no I guess that would be crazy I mean
it was just there's usually about like
two hours after the show wasn't been the
same since like Connie and jay-z
sang a song and also telestroke sang a
song and Rihanna yeah and also Justin
Bieber and Katy Perry
it used to be sender ariana grande it
used to be so good actually really like
the performances Shawn Mendes
I am such a grandmother because I don't
really listen to like top music anymore
I just like do my Spotify release right
arm but every once in a while a popular
song crosses my desk and I text niche
and I'm like oh my god I love this song
and it's like number one loss it really
lost in Japan is one of those songs I'm
in love with it also ruined my life by
zara larsson is the best song ever it's
the best jumper no I'm just saying
that's another I wrote ami about that's
where I'm so late to the party it's
lemon Ave that's the way she network
that song is for us because like it's so
fast yes so good that's how we talked
about that song it's so good aunt Esther
I love Shawn Mendes his performance and
in light of his interview I was watching
the whole show differently do you think
he got any tail um
do I think he got any tail yeah I think
I hope he did I was hoping maybe him in
uh Nadine Leopold held hands for a
second today
yeah and I'm shipit' she used to date
Harry Styles yeah for like she would
link to yes for one second yeah um I
loved her from model squad oh right and
she was one who's really honest about
the fact that she was like I did not eat
for two weeks leading up to the
auditions but if you're gonna be if
you're gonna if you're gonna okay ready
here if you were going to set an
unrealistic beauty standard for women
please be realistic about how you got
there you know I totally agree I love
Barbara Palvin though and I saw she was
in two outfits and literally they put
her in sweatpants they covered her whole
body miking but that was the theme it
was I guess their sports collect
athleisure this show was so stupid like
I'm I will be so happy when it gets
canceled no same and I think we're I
want to see what the numbers were
because I think we're changing towards
that I mean people are just not happy
and they fear you know that as it could
have just kept his mouth closed for ten
more like literally ten more days and
made his like unincluded homophobic
comments afterwards like it really
would've helped the ratings I agree and
what was I going
I forgot something oh they definitely
made all of the girls cuz in the past
they never know the songs and they're
like just being awkward on the runway
they made them memorize every single
lyric yeah cuz everyone was singing the
songs in the back end not all of them
were popular songs right like I don't
think they all know the lyrics that
Kelsea Ballerini song then the struts
performed
and I was laughing because one time in
trivial sorry not trivial pursuits
categories we it was like a music band
and the letter was s and they did the
strats and everyone was like that's not
a band but they performed it I was right
and they're not very well-known in
America and everyone knew the lyrics ya
know I mean it's first of all most of
the girls their English is not their
first language so the odds of them
knowing a song every word is unlikely
also like when you're famous you don't
know other famous songs you know right
unless it's like closer by Halsey like
everyone would have known the words set
because it was the biggest song in the
world or like the middle I wonder why
the middle didn't perform I think it's
because it's its past they're not
currently promoting it this is her songs
that like they are on the current loop
yeah yeah that's true Halsey looked like
amazing like I love when like Taylor
Swift when she perform like she could
have been a model and I felt the same
about Halsey I felt the same about all
the Rita or mbb wrecks that really
they'll see those like hell sees legs
I'm sorry so intimidating to like go up
there and sing like wearing some like I
have so much respect I mean I [ __ ]
love we're gonna meet her tomorrow oh my
god I know I'm so excited cuz all these
women like just because you did so much
confidence and they're dancing they're
having fun the women who sang also the
women who walked performed yeah like I
don't blame them for being confident um
no I just like can't and like I just
feel like the girls who get promoted
within Victoria's Secret like are the
girls who like nobody ever says like
mean things to their faces do you know
what I mean then like I'm just like not
that i promote negativity at all but
it's like I'm glad like some negativity
is being directed towards like this
group of people I'm sorry like they
can't work Generale let GG like they get
whatever they want for their whole lives
like they were born rich and famous and
beautiful and there's a rigid I rich
it's like you know like they need to
they need to feel this I'm sorry I know
that's me to say because I don't think
like that people should be spoken to
Roget down like down to but like I'm
sorry they need this I agree okay next
story is just a cute little story of six
stories today because it was a busy
weekend but Karlie Kloss quote clearly
knows her stuff after converting to
Judaism yes cuz she got married no no I
didn't burn yeah I guess we were on the
fence but Karlie Kloss spent Shabbat
with husband Josh Kushner at an event
for Britain's former chief rabbi Lord
Jonathan Sacks oh my god he's a lord
yeah
Laura get you a guy who can do both
claws who converted to Judaism was
reading in Hebrew and quote clearly
knows her stuff according to onlookers a
source added quote they blended in as
for anything to do with Kushner's boy
brother Jared someone said someone asked
about politics and they said religion is
a unifier and separate from politics
Greg came Leah she knows Hebrew I can't
let me she knows Hebrew like honestly
we're one step closer to Taylor Swift
that's magic Taylor Swift became Jewish
oh my god but she like I feel like she
loves her good Christian values
I agree but maybe for the right guy you
never know that's true I mean Joe is not
Jewish no she needs to do the Jewish
businessman an international businessman
a man carries a briefcase oh my god I
forgot to tell everyone I did I got my
23andme results oh yeah and we were
finally gonna put to bed whether or not
did they not tell you though that it was
tainted with your lipstick they didn't I
guess I didn't come up as a factory in
California that makes colour-pop
cosmetics and Kylie cosmetics I didn't
come up as a generous sister how sad so
but I tells us jack is adopted everyone
always asked some ask some asks if I'm
adopted oh that's if I'm adopted and I
know that I'm not but I really never had
proof like maybe I was switched in the
hospital and I should be the start of a
free-form show called switch at first
yeah and I couldn't prove that that
wasn't true and I was like even if I'm
not adopted or switched scheppers I
definitely have different like genetic
makeup than everyone else maybe I'm a
little bit more Irish you know someone
came in who knows anyways and you had
your twenty three Emmys story of you
know your friend's dad 29 June your
friend's dad was 98 percent you as she's
dog going around telling everyone the
community Claudia does her she's 99% geo
a nine point nine percent Ashkenazi
Jewish Gen dot it he was a hundred
percent I couldn't believe it I got mine
I am 100 percent Ashkenazi Jewish I
couldn't be more your sister if I tried
and I feel even more certain that you
and Ben are related yeah no that was
basically all of this comes back to one
conclusion
yeah Ben is our cousin and we've been
engaging in incest for about five years
now
no we need everyone to do 23andme so
that they can do like a family chat we
can see like
where you intend upon ancestry - yeah
but it's just so hard because being like
Eastern European Jewish is like there's
so many people were killed during the
Holocaust like it's really hard to tie
like death records because their people
died and they never had funerals they
never had death records they were buried
in a mass grave like so there's really
it's hard to trace back your family tree
so much when your Eastern European but
we got to do it we got to do it and I
now I know my route like I'm just pure
Ashkenazi Jew it's just really I will
look at awk I don't look it at all I I
knew I was like I knew that I'm your
sister we actually do all look alike
when you put us all together but I
didn't think I was gonna be more than
you well how are you handling this I
mean it's just upsetting cuz like I was
like the top like nobody had ever been
99.9 and then like you in abadan came
and like took a big old steaming dump on
that so thank you for taking away like
the one thing that happens and now I
need some exact do it yeah so that I can
make sure like he's not you know just
like 75 right but everyone should do
their 23 me I feel like it's and they by
the way I bought my kit on sale you can
buy your kit on sale too but also the
more and more people that do it the more
information they have and the more
information other people can get from it
right so it's like a you're not only
getting information but you're
contributing to the DNA database which
will help millions of other people
yes and you know maybe if you were Swiss
scheppers this is what I'm gonna find
out now through December 25th get 30%
off any 23andme kit order your DNA kit
at 23andme comm slash toast that's the
number two three a nd me.com slash toast
again that's 23andme comm slash toast I
highly recommend it for everyone I think
oh it's the future we need to know where
we come from in order to know where
we're going
amen like for me I found out pertinent
information so now I can shut down all
the haters who just want to say that I'm
adopted right you know it's not
necessarily insulting but it's like when
people keep asking me if I'm adopted
like I start to question like am i
different from my sister everybody it's
the Khloe Kardashian of it all yeah or
the Khloe Kardashian's actly what it is
and now I have my results from 23 me and
I'm just gonna put them in your face to
shut down the haters just a bunch of
celebrity sisters partnering up with
23andme
just a bunch of celebrity sisters
partnering up for 23 miles I feel like
we've done seven thousand stories also
had written kinda lists of things that
we are two more briefs but I just want
to remember like if we if we got it we
did Alabama hold on we're not done yet
okay actually just one more story I'm
gonna take that one out of the couple
who dropped their ring and oh it way
great it's really cute but they found it
very New York specific and found it
fifth and final story um I did this one
for you friends fans are up in arms over
the show leaving Netflix in January
friends fans had a bitter pill to
swallow when they checked Netflix this
weekend after being on the streaming
site for several years now it appears
that the hit comedy is set to leave the
popular streaming service on January 1st
2019 quote Netflix is going to stop
streaming friends on January 1st
I don't expect except expressions of I
don't expect expressions of sympathy but
they'd certainly be appreciated well you
should wouldn't user wrote that's all
these there's all these tweets of people
who are devastated so now I just start
off I know you are leading let me just
start off by saying okay well I was just
checking my I made it change.org
petition this morning because I don't
know when you feel helpless I just feel
like making a petition like it's a good
way to get nothing done but feel like
you're doing something and I just say
we've we were about to reach 3,000
signatures I feel like this is gonna go
viral I mean it two hours ago where can
people sign it so it's on my Instagram
bio it's in my Lincoln bio on my girl
with no job page it's also a swipe up
link it's in the toasters group it's
called save friends 2019 friends is
officially leaving Netflix on January
1st this is unfair unacceptable
downright inhumane Simon show the
petition holding epics accountable
hashtag justice for friends okay I just
want to say if you would if this has
happened last week I would have said
you're [ __ ] out of luck but something
happened to me at the end of last week
that made me renew my faith in petitions
because years back I was starting and
signing petitions to bring back TCB one
of hi one of my favorite shows of all
time that only had one season and had a
star-studded roster it was the most
underrated show of all time and last
week it was announced that CW is
bringing back JC I can't believe it and
if I pluck that show from obscurity
there was really no demand to bring it
back no sides from you besides for me
and I I feel like just like Heather
McMahon did when she came on the show
and she was talking about the most
random shot with designing women this is
Rick it was like a reality show of like
older women like designing
in Atlanta she was like it really
pioneered something something I would
love for it to come back not one day
later reboot of Designing Women it was
so great manifest destiny
I agree ask believe receive so I'm just
saying your petition isn't nothing no
but it's like the players here are just
so big like it's Netflix and Warner
Brothers and Rachel but this isn't even
a big ask asking to bring back a show
right that was Bergen with budget with
with high a list actors and it wasn't
watching us or Kristin Chenoweth or the
other basically did you love her I loved
her
Alicia [ __ ] long legs elizabeth long
legs yeah oh my gosh okay well here's
the thing well now meeting here's the
thing the thing is that on this
change.org petition you can leave
comments like reasons why you're
passionate about this cause and people
are saying like how friends impacts
their lives and it's so funny because I
feel like people who love friends and
like watch it all the time really watch
it the same way like I watch friends as
more like a background like when I'm
doing work on my computer and I'm
sending you a thousand face times and
emails like I'm friends is on in the
background Theo
everyone says my dog loves it I leave it
on for my job I told you field likes
friends it's a very calming force um
I fall asleep to it it's like when I
when I'm home alone or I'm in a hotel
and I'm alone and I'm like afraid to be
in the dark
I put friends on and just fall asleep to
it and like it eventually turns off we
all watch it the same way you know yeah
so guys please go to my Instagram
Lincoln bio honestly I'm only doing it
because I know like BuzzFeed's gonna
write up that friends is getting taken
off and like they're gonna use my
petition yeah I wonder what the decision
behind this is because maybe some
another streaming service will pick it
out maybe Hulu could be live with that
well I could because I have a toasters
Hulu Liz hi I'm like me and her family
watch TV together and I've really took
the next step on her Hulu account and
made myself my own profile that's the
way to go because then you get tailored
right so and I want started watching
shark tank that's why but so maybe it'll
become on another streaming service and
that would be okay but like this is I
mean I don't pay for a Netflix account I
never have we all have one big family
account there's literally seven profiles
on it but if I did pay for it like and I
still see again on my credit card bill
every month I might now cancel it I was
really I was really I haven't been on
Netflix and maybe not having to do with
friends
in six months like since I moved 20
apartment I haven't watched Netflix once
except to watch friends interesting I
really I do feel for you because I've
been there like I've had I know the
feeling that you're going through so I
was gonna make an insensitive joke what
were you gonna say you know that they're
taking it down to make room for better
shows but imagine though that we didn't
say that like not only you hurt my
feelings but you hurt the feelings of a
millions of Americans I know I know
that's why I'm about this that's why I'm
not gonna say it but you just did I just
talked to my friend a because he's gonna
be really upset cuz he looks a lot like
David Rimmer no he doesn't
oh my god you're kidding me he is Ross
David Schwimmer is not cute by the way
David Schwimmer is cute and so I was
aimed Abe's cute yeah but so is David
Schwimmer I don't think when he was in
friends who's cute and like I mean don't
get me started about how Ross is like
the real catch on the show and like
everyone was acting like he was a big
loser cuz like he was inside Snerd but
he was only one with like a real [ __ ]
job and a PhD and tenure and all he
wanted to do was like have kids and move
to the suburbs and was like a good guy
who could commit and he was like to
committal for Rachel she was a piece of
work okay
yeah I could really do like a TED talk I
like analyzing the friendships you
should because there was really
something wrong with Monica and Ross's
brother-sister relationship it was very
inappropriate you should do a podcast
episode I know a patron episode speaking
of patron and speaking of 23 me we're
doing an episode I'm so excited with
Ben's mom oh yeah Ava about the
documentary three identicals I wonder
what she has to say I want to see her
talk Youmans I want to just hear about
her experience and hear her thoughts on
the movie like I someone who's very
close to it as someone who who lived it
almost oh my could have lived it is
craziness
I wonder I want to get her take on
whether or not she's and she has twin
because I strongly believe that it like
that she does that there's something
more to the story also I wanted to talk
about last night's episode of
Kardashians you didn't watch so I won't
really talk about the content nothing
really crazy Kim goes back to Paris for
Virgil's show oh really it was a good
episode very enjoyable they did the City
of Hope poker tournament Lala's on it
she's not speaking but she's in the
background Randall's on it he's like
pretty um they could do a practice poker
game and he's like really being like
a ham like keeps talking like okay yeah
I don't want to say thirsty cuz like I
don't know who's doing it for the
cameras but he's like a big personality
I think um so the episode was good but
there's something I just want to address
because they're doing Virgil's show
which was September Paris Fashion Week
the last episodes were of Chloe's birth
which was in April
Tristan's cheating Chloe's birth was in
April that was right when we started the
toast so and Virgil stashes so September
so they made a huge leap so I was like
oh I guess they just didn't film for six
months because Chloe was in Cleveland
and myoblast Obama is skipping ahead but
the next week's episode is about Kanye's
album launch in Wyoming him going on TMZ
Alice Marie Johnson oh that's literally
like three months ago no that's when we
were in Turks and Caicos so that is also
April so they're just like really
jumping around and I'm so weird and I
really I really don't like that and I'm
sure they have their reasons because
they want the final episode to be like
the most traumatic and this was a lot of
like individual storylines it was the
poker game it was going back to Paris
and it was Kourtney freezing her eggs
but she did she got seven eggs out whoo
so I'm sure that what you said last week
that they tried to have a fourth kid
yeah and it didn't take it's true it's
probably true um so that was just like
one episode where it really didn't rely
on time but it's just annoying as a
viewer to feel do eggs like that and
like that
really produced in faith well oh and
they started the episode talking about
the reaction that people have had to
watching Kim say that Kourtney's at
least interesting to look at and
Kardashian's premiered in like October
wait that's crazy so that was literally
in like late September or October that's
a good month ago I know
that's not and then they're gonna go
back to April I just it's hard to keep
up as a mom saying for a show that it's
hell-bent on having their audience keep
up they're making it awfully difficult
they're making it awfully difficult I
started the new season of shark tank cuz
I've heard such good things from you and
just from everyone and obviously it
hasn't disappointed it's such a good
show and the gate I've gotten to see the
the ring guy bead the shark he was good
he was very astute very smart the ring
guy yeah the doorbell oh yes yeah the
first shark picture to become the shark
the shark II the shark at it was obvious
that guy that they brought in with the
box for the scanning of the packages
like was really made for Amazon and I
keep saying such smart things and it
really was like if you're gonna have an
invention because me a member saying we
need to get an invention going obviously
your invention needs to solve a problem
but it can't enter and this other guy
said it can't interrupt user behavior
like I'm used to getting packages a
certain way I'm not gonna change my life
because I bought this thing you know
right I'll cheat I was watching an old
episode where mark says something's so
smart he said you've you've solved you
have a solution and now you're trying to
identify the problem right that what the
problem is sometimes by the way you
don't need to invent something the toast
was made for Shark Tank I think about
the toast on Shark Tank all the time any
time we make a business decision I think
about what mr. wonderful would say like
what are our margins like hi how are we
what's our customer acquisition cost
zero zero zero social media ever heard
of it no so if you really want to be on
Shark Tank the toast is where what to
take well I got to see Charles Barkley
like he was not as selected as I thought
it was gonna be he like he's a because I
only I watch him because bed makes me
watch him and Shaq and then they have
this whole report he's like a really
funny guy and I just don't think that
really came across oh I was watching and
I was like hey this guy's kind of funny
for an athlete Sara Blakely the space
girl I just really can't stand her like
I think she's still boring really
and everything she like is interested in
or invests in like is the worst
companies that come on she invested in
that last time she was there that dad
like I'm single dad but paternal
clothing brand
what like paternity clothes what it was
the worst idea I ever heard and it was
just like she's clothed so their clothes
like hated it that drink that everyone
wanted cave shake that the coca-cola
incubator has 15% of I was like I
couldn't believe it Charles Barkley
ended up doing it I couldn't believe
everyone was so hungry for them it did
the worst branding it was a shake I was
like the girls were so annoying they
didn't know any of the the outlet they
didn't know that the details of their
deal with it coca-cola they couldn't
even speak Commission 10% over time that
they didn't know I was like why the
brand I mean the companies that everyone
loves I don't understand I don't
understand either and then that guy with
the broom and the dustpan which was
[ __ ] genius then with the stepping
down she yeah I know he should have
bought the product cuz his brand was
[ __ ] he was in debt he owed everyone
money he had so much inventory like it
was useless but his patent lorry should
have bought the patent and made her own
like Joy brand lorry brand of that
[ __ ] thing no I was literally on my
floor last night with my desk pan
back-breaking huh
and I was like I need a [ __ ] wisp the
step is G nice I'm actually gonna I
think he's still in business you should
I gotta get what that's the problem yet
I don't I feel like sometimes they let a
great idea go just because the business
isn't there but these creators aren't
business savvy right and I think if it's
a great idea like the rest unless
they're like ten million dollars in debt
like the rest should fall by the wayside
Oh with the apple juice with apple sauce
apple sauce she was she was making like
artisanal apple sauce and she was like
if you want to buy apple sauce its
marketed towards 90 year olds or nine
year olds like there's no apple sauce
like Chobani made yogurt was for kids
until Giovanni told adults that they
could eat it and at first I thought it
was so stupid in bed was like no it's
genius she's creating a category I mean
it was so smart and they were railing on
her for not giving up her job at News
Corp like you're not a real entrepreneur
if you're not homeless like I that's
where the show loses me where it's like
you can have an entrepreneurial spirit
and be really committed to your brand in
your product but still need to put food
on the table and she was like she was
like so many people rely on me like I'm
the breadwinner of my family my mom my
dad and all my siblings rely on me
financially I'm she start crying she's
like I'm the person for my family who
quote-unquote made it and for you to ask
for me to quit my very good job in
publishing at News Corp it's so
unrealistic and I couldn't have agreed
with her more and I was so glad that she
started fighting back because they get
so in their heads about this this
episode I immunize about Apple song yeah
this stereotype that they've created for
and when in the beginning of every
episode they say shark tank has ignited
the entrepreneurial spirit in America
and that is true and they've created the
stereotype of like entrepreneurs have to
one it's so bed got to give it all up
mortgage your house refinance your house
take out your form okay why why can't
you have a good idea be committed to a
brand and still have kids and a family
that you provide for like I was getting
so mad but Marc ended up investing and
she's gonna be a billionaire that woman
I'm happy for a way people are
commenting just
couple clarifications are saying that
virtual show was in June and so was
Alice Marie Johnson I'll have to look
that up but either way they're jumping
around a lot and I'm out here for it
also the Lila Kent City of Hope thing
was not very long ago when they had
their mom yes right no well so I was
literally in the fall I'm where I'm nuts
um but yeah sorry I just like needed to
go off and then there was a guy for
reward stock which was not really the
points guys EPG
yeah the points guys brand ripped off
when I was texting on like have you
heard of this he's like he didn't wanna
talk about I was like getting so [ __ ]
incensed he's still a brand's opposed
guys whole brand and when mr. wonderful
was like have you ever heard of the
brand I thought it was gonna say the
points guy cuz it was so similar but he
was like honey whatever yeah I find is
that what the extender I mean the
extension on the browser that I use no
mind is like a honeymoon fund oh well I
thought that they were gonna say the
points can I was like but they didn't
and it was such a cheap knockoff version
agreed what do you think about Matt
Higgins I haven't seen him yet I only
had up steps with three or four we
didn't see the no hitch no he pitch no
delivery was watching just to get to the
pitch but I had to go to sleep I
understand
LCDC a rod no Bethenny I miss the
Bethenny episode she's on next week
though this week's episode there was no
guest shark and I'm realizing I'm here
for the guest shot I was gonna say so
when I was watching it went back to they
had Barbara and Lori and Daymond like
and it was like I want give me I think
even take Sara Blakely okay like I just
want someone I just want someone who's
like work I'm familiar with because not
unless we go on Shark Tank I don't know
really like what mr. wonderful does well
I he had a chill he I don't know like I
know what he's done with shark tank he
has the wines and this and stuff and
we're cupcakes wicked good cupcakes oh
my god if Robert Herjavec brings up
[ __ ] tipsy yelps one more time like
we get okay but tipsy else is one of the
top five most successful totally but
it's like every time he even thinks
about investing he references the one
company like when when they bring up
their other companies or their other
investments they'd all have like a huge
portfolio of things to choose her Robert
has just tipsy elves and when his wife
came with the baby carrier and his wife
came and brought their two kids that I
didn't see oh it was like it was cute
but like I have a hard time forgetting
that he like left his wife of 30 years
you know that's not what happened it's
not no I don't think that he jumped from
one ship to another I think there was
like a break in between and he was like
really depressed is what I read oh well
what I'm like maybe like saved him but
what I heard from our sister Olivia was
when he was still married she saw him in
the Delta Sky Lounge with her so right
while they were tense with the Stars
partners but they might have been still
married legally but like I think they
were most definitely separated the
definitely sounds like some publicist
who Nagi I don't know I just I really
like Robert I'm gonna tell my mum how my
petition is doing oh the people are
watching this I guess it's like a lot to
do we're at 3,000 okay we got 3400 I'm
telling you we're going viral City of
Hope game was July 29th you know what
let's put how about you why do you put
together a timeline I will I will
anyways do we have anything else to
discuss before we wrap up I had a list
and go live Kim chose shark tank
Kardashians got it got it all I could
talk about shark tank forever though
okay well here's what you need to do you
need to sign my petition to save friends
because it's not gonna really do
anything but BuzzFeed might write me up
and like maybe link to my Instagram and
I can get like five followers that would
be great but before you do that I want
everyone to get their get their phones
get their tablets computers their
Eventbrite mobile apps and I want you to
do me a favor
they're Eventbrite mobile apps no good
beer where you posting it I'm about to
post the link in the morning toasters
Facebook group on the YouTube stream so
if you're watching live right now you
can get I'm going to comment right now
with the link and then I'm gonna tell
you the password it's still password
protected because okay morning toast is
saying something link is going live
right now password is all caps Kent and
shan't no apostrophes shook to the core
I'm just like let's wait a minute like
I'm posting it everywhere I emailed you
the link post it in our in our Instagram
bio on the morning toast just in case
you're listening to the podcast right
now Canton chants all caps no
apostrophes should do an Instagram story
on our toaster curtsy to the bio first
so people can go straight there okay it
in the by oh wow this is so exciting
we've never done a live life yeah well
that's the thing with live television
ladies and gentlemen all right it's up
Jake mm do an Instagram story okay
should see the password on the story
yes hey guys we are live on the Warnie
toast
right now but more importantly our camp
does tickets just one up for sale for
everyone so swipe the [ __ ] up get
yourself a ticket
the password is can't and shan't conte
and shot no apostrophes swipe app will
summer we'll see you this summer all
caps oh my god I'm so excited
okay let's just wait for those you know
those confirmation emails to start
rolling in
should I type captain Chen yes you
should and that was really like a lot of
adrenaline I'm so excited for cam toes
by the way juicy Instagram added this
new thing when you go to press add story
where you used to press it now says
close friends yes Anu oh my god do you
know me [ __ ] times I keep pressing I
know I thank you sure it's I hate when
when technology and media companies
start getting new features and they
think the way to get people to use them
is to switch the places like when
Twitter invented moments which never
took off they switched in my browser
where notifications was to moment so I
kept accidentally going to moments so
they use that in their metrics when they
said like look we got all these people
to click it was an accident the thing
about Instagram though I think they'll
realize if people aren't using it
they'll pivot yeah so just don't use it
please I am NOT of X again anyways we're
so sad to see you a cam toast Memorial
Day weekend 2019 tickets are live now
tickets include food clothing alcohol
free murder shelter merch open bar
friendship or a life chips bonds and if
you're on the fence about going honestly
just ask some of the toasters who went
like it's incredible if you're going
alone do not worry I think probably most
people came alone majority of people
like 60% of people had come alone and
now they're all coming together like
they're theirs they're coming still
technically alone but they're all like
driving up to there cuz now they know
each other they've been keeping in touch
all year right and then once you buy
your ticket you get the link to the cam
toast group cam toes to group so you can
talk with everyone else who's going and
figure out who's in your area maybe you
can travel with them carpool road trip
carpool karaoke watch out Tucson here we
come
guys we love you thank you for the
endless support we can't me just see you
at CEM toast and we will also see you
tomorrow morning
you